so g2's golden boy modesty has been
called out for abusing a smoke bug at
the 2022 antwerp major the bug allowed
him to basically mow down his opponents
while they couldn't see him at all
now he's claimed that admins allowed him
to use the bug but in a really weird
turn of events valve actually patched it
out mid-event this actually goes really
deep so let's dive into it
[Music]
alright guys as you know there's a lot
of cs go content coming out right now so
if you want to stay up to date i think
it's in your best interest if you
subscribe to the channel and leave a
like if you like the video the pgl major
is in full swing right now and it's
honestly been incredible but since this
is cs go we're talking about it's not
been without its fair share of
controversy and if you've been paying
attention to any of those controversies
the one we're talking about today
stemmed from just a single smoke grenade
in a game last weekend against fallen's
last dance squad imperial g2's 17 year
old opera threw a smoke grenade that
acted as a one-way essentially the smoke
allowed him to see all the way down mid
without being spotted himself this let
him pick apart the unsuspecting
brazilians
[Music]
[Music]
now one way smokes are not outlawed at
all in pro play but what makes this
smoke different is it actually negated
the effects of a previously thrown smoke
from his perspective to put it simply
imperial threw your standard mid-window
smoke from t-spawn but monacy learned
that his counter-smoke would make a
section of that original smoke invisible
when crouched in his specific position
okay so this is definitely not the
intended function of csgo's engine which
would technically make this smoke an
exploit three clicks phillip also
noticed that both modesty and hunter
attempted to smoke in several other
rounds against imperial on top of that
monastery also managed to pull off that
exact same smoke in a match against
na'vi
[Music]
and started out with the kills
oh one way from monacy
what makes the imperial situation worse
is that g2 ended up beating them only 16
to 12. that's a pretty close match if
you ask me
so once the clip started making the
rounds people got pretty heated
monastery was quick to explain what
happened on twitter in a reply to don
hachi saying that he asked admins ahead
of time if the smoke was illegal and
they told him it was okay to use shortly
after pgl tweeted that they would
continue to allow the smoke to be used
and that they were on the current
version of cs go okay so i'm not too
sure why they needed to clarify that
they were on the latest client of cs go
this is a major tournament after all so
if they weren't that would be very
bizarre
i just assumed this was a way to wash
their hands of any responsibility
unfortunately for pgl this did not
absolve them in the eyes of the
community in fact people just ended up
flaming them even harder since modesty
clearly wasn't at fault now all this is
actually pretty concerning to the
integrity of the tournament because this
smoke can hypothetically be recreated on
any map in certain areas if you took the
time to try and because of pgl's in
action all the teams remaining ended up
making a gentleman's agreement not to
use the smoke bug but in a surprising
twist valve actually ended up fixing the
bug and patching it out within 24 hours
of the issue being brought to light i
say it's surprising because things like
this happen like once a year and valve
never does what would you say
you do here
but as i mentioned at the top this
actually goes a bit deeper you see this
isn't the first time an exploit has been
used at a major tournament most recently
there was the illegal molotov at blast
which resulted in admins making the call
to redo the round then there was of
course the famous olaf boost in 2014
which resulted in the game being
forfeited after to's ruled against it
and perhaps the most similar case to
this situation was the notorious big
jump bug from the 2017 pgl major where
once again pgl allowed the exploit to be
used resulting in teams deciding to make
their own gentlemen's agreement not to
use it what connects all these incidents
together is that every time valve never
lifted a finger to actually solve any of
the problems do something do something
do something but that's what makes this
smoke bug so interesting valve quickly
patched it out and things went on
business as usual now that match still
did count as a loss for imperials so
fans were rightfully a little upset
about the situation but both teams are
now out of the tournament so
such is life i suppose and it luckily
seems like modesty didn't actually catch
too much of the blame at first in fact
he's kind of a whistleblower if you
think about it first of all like a
well-behaved young man modesty decided
to ask for permission before using the
bug and secondly this isn't the first
time that monasty's brought a bug to
everybody's attention in fact it's not
even the first time it's been about a
smoke grenade look i'll show you a good
strategy smoking g2
from this bench
then you're coming here for example
for example bots are staying like this
okay
[Music]
like this and this right
if you
aim here
late like
this know you can see
around the smoke then
now on a final note there's something i
wanted to mention as a cs go fan and
someone who's been watching since the
olaf boost i think this controversy
tells us something about the current
state of cs go for starters it shows
that cs go is definitely still broken
and that these things are going to
happen again but more importantly it
tells us that when valve a to or someone
with authority actually makes a popular
common sense decision
the drama tends to die out pretty
quickly and especially now after all the
coaching bug drama i think it's clear
that valve needs to start taking more
responsibility for their game
after all they made it
this is definitely not the intended use
of valorent's valorum jesus oops have i
ever abused a bug for cs go no i i don't
think i'm i don't think i'm smart enough
to abuse a bug like
the effort that monasty had to put in to
actually learn how to do this is
insane and i don't think i have that
type of
time on my hands to be honest with you